Bobby fiser continue with his plan he
captured the Knight here on C3 again
trying to remove this defender of the E4
Pawn now keep in mind uh burn has two
options he can capture with his Pawn or
he can capture with his Queen but he
knows that really Bobby fiser wants to
come in and take this Pawn on e4 and
once he does this then this Pawn on E7
is going to be hanging so right now he
doesn't want to take with his Queen
because he wants two attackers his Queen
on A3 and his Bishop on G5 to both be
attacking this Pawn here on E7 so just
keep in mind that burn does take with
his Pawn you know from B2 but that's why
if you're wondering why didn't he take
with his Queen um that's exactly why